the sun will change from a red giant to
a white dwarf
this means it will shrink until it
becomes the size of Earth today it will
blast off massive amounts of X-ray
radiation but less heat so the habitable
zone will dramatically shift once again
it could go from the Kuiper belt to
about where mercury used to be for a
human civilization to continue we'd have
to move onto another star's habitable
exoplanet
our white dwarf star would radiate for
quadrillions of years so moving back to
its new habitable zone wouldn't be a
good idea
when our former son used up the last of
its energy it will no longer be able to
shine or radiate heat